[موسيقى]
في بعض الأحيان يدغدغونني لفترة طويلة
ويغمضون أعينهم ويتكئون للخلف وكأنهم
مرتاحون
ولم أكن أعرف كم من الوقت سأبقى
هناك، قال إنه يجب علي أن أكون في مكان ما
وكنت كذلك  لا أستطيع الذهاب، لقد أصبت بختم
على ساقي في أول لقاء مع
بيرل، كان يومًا جميلاً
ولاحظت بيرل في الجانب
وقامت بركلتين كبيرتين على زعانفها الخلفيتين
مباشرة نحوي لذلك كنت على ما
يرام.  يجب أن أذهب إلى
وضع التجميد حيث تحدثت للتو
هناك، فهي تأتي وتمسك بركبتي
وتبدأ تيبي في النقر بعيدًا وبمجرد أن
ينخرطوا في الأمر حقًا مثل
الدغدغة والنقر عليها، يبدو تقريبًا أنهم
يبتسمون من
ملفهم الشخصي الجانبي
فقمة المرفأ لديهم فضول كبير بشأن
القمامة، كما رأيت فقمة مع
مقبض كيس بقالة حول رقبتها
ولحسن الحظ فقد خرجت منه، وأنا أعلم أن ذلك
سيكون له إمكانية قتل
حيوان ثديي بحري
ولكن جزء التنظيف أسميه مثل
ضريبة المحيطات، يبدو الأمر كما لو كنت تخرج وترى
كل هذه الأشياء المذهلة، أقل ما
يمكنك فعله هو إخراج بعض القمامة معك، كلما قلت
النفايات التي نضعها في محيطاتنا،
كلما تمكنت هذه الفقمات من العيش
حياة طويلة وسعيدة